first of all thank you all for coming
today and I'm gonna try to do three
things hopefully successfully I'm gonna
try to address the current lay of the
land then answer a question that
probably is unanswerable but we'll try
what would Richard Nixon do if he faced
the same circumstances number two and
number three what does the book say what
does it recommend and why is it
different from what's going on in
Washington and indeed the country today
so those are my parameters today and I
do think to start I oughta
share a little context I was one of
those and there were many million
Americans who did this as well who
didn't vote for president I had worked
for Bill Clinton as some of you may know
and I just decided that Hillary Clinton
was a bridge too far and so on Fox News
I did make it very clear that I could
not would not support Secretary Clinton
got a fair amount of publicity but I
didn't say that I would support Donald
Trump I'd worked for mr. Trump in a
private capacity in his business I knew
him and my own philosophy and view of
government is very different from his
and so I just said look I'm just not
gonna get involved not make a choice but
speak out however I believe is necessary
and appropriate well as I sit here today
I'm probably one of the few commentators
you might hear or see who doesn't have
an axe to grind
put another way I didn't as I said
support Donald Trump I didn't support
Secretary Clinton didn't vote for
president I am still a Democrat there's
much about the left wing of the
Democratic Party that I can't associate
myself with
there's much about the right wing of the
Republican Party that I also can't
associate myself with so I'm in the
middle I tried to do that on my
appearances on Fox News is to you know
just offer a centrist perspective and
hopefully a common-sense and logical
perspective I leave that to others to
determine but my book America in the age
of Trump tries to forge common-sense
bipartisan solutions to the problems we
are facing and I would argue that those
problems are getting worse and they're
being to a great degree made worse still
by our political leadership first let me
start with the president I have two
problems look philosophically I disagree
with a lot of what he has tried to do
but and I think it's fair to say much of
what he has proposed is within the realm
of reason I could disagree as I do with
his health care plan I might not support
from what's been released his tax reform
plan I probably would have appointed a
different Supreme Court judge justice
but let's be very clear let's be very
clear everything the president has
proposed is within the realm of reason
and can be considered and negotiated and
then we'll get to in a second what would
Richard Nixon do and I dare say
President Nixon would have approached
things very differently than President
Trump I think like a lot of people I was
heartened by this speech on Monday night
he set out of clear policy for
Afghanistan made it clear where he was
different from President Obama and
what's come before and outlined an
approach towards Afghanistan towards
Pakistan and indeed towards South Asia
generally but to be completely candid
when I saw what he said and did in
Phoenix yesterday my heart sank
look.we my perspective is pretty direct
and pretty simple we are all Americans
we all have a common interest and if we
don't pursue our common interest as
Americans we all lose and that's what
our adversaries whether it be North
Korea Iran or the Chinese or the
Russians that's what they're hoping for
that we will in our own way divide fight
among ourselves and we caná-- still I
think it was the case that Secretary of
Defense mattis said that our greatest
enemy is here at home and I certainly
share those sentiments in that worldview
because if we cannot get our own house
in order and stop attacking we have a
profound problem so from my point of
view to polarize as the president does
and I say that with a heavy heart
because I think most of it is really
unnecessary I think what he said about
Charlottesville was unnecessary and on
help well I know the man he's not a
racist he's not an anti-semite but
certainly to say that there were some
fine people in Charlottesville and to
equate left-wing protestors however
offensive with neo-nazis and white
supremists is to me unacceptable and
that he doubled down yet again yesterday
is deeply deeply upsetting but it's also
upsetting to me and I'm not going to try
to quantify amounts more or less
whatever but it's certainly upsetting to
me that the Democratic Party is the
party of resistance my heart sinks
because I was brought up in the 60s
where we had a bipartisan tradition we
did the civil rights legislation voting
rights Medicare Medicaid all done
with Democratic and Republican
bipartisanship and maybe I'm old enough
or perhaps naive enough to believe that
we can still do that and I would hope we
could so far though given the way the
Democratic Party is operating the
chances of that are almost minimal and
when I look at people like Bernie
Sanders and I look at Elizabeth Warren I
say to myself look we're a capitalist
country we believe in free markets we
believe in Liberty we don't believe that
the answer to everything is to tax the
rich or somehow believe that those who
have had success in life are in some way
inherently evil and need to be punished
I think that's just wrong too and it
leaves me literally out in the cold with
a level of sadness about what's
happening to our country that makes me
as disappointed as possible I was hoping
that Donald Trump would govern like
Richard Nixon if you remember the 68
campaign and I can see that at least
some of you are old enough to remember
that campaign but most not Richard Nixon
had a Southern Strategy he talked tough
a lot and he got enough of the Wallace
vote to win parts of the south and
certainly the the mid-south area as well
as much of the Midwest but the Nixon
rhetorical strategy if you remember
watch what I do not what I say was
exactly that Nixon I argue in my book
the Nixon in effect governed in a
bipartisan way
his agenda I make the argument in that
book was actually more liberal than much
of what we see today the EPA we see that
he proposed a guaranteed annual income
there was more integration done
in the Nixon administration and I think
in any prior time and if you assess his
presidency he consciously and
consistently governed in a way that was
designed to if nothing else unify the
country on a policy basis and for those
who didn't like President Nixon and
certainly there were plenty of those he
did get 49 percent of the vote in 1972
and over I think 60 percent of the
popular vote if my memory serves me
right around 60 percent so this is a man
who was a consummate leader and on
foreign policy with the opening to China
the beginnings of day taunt this was a
man who was a visionary sadly we don't
have that today I hope and pray that
Donald Trump's speech is the beginning
of a strategy that involves a more
assertive America and seeks to position
ourselves to deal with the many threats
we are facing whether they be in North
Korea in the Middle East but to me the
question is still an open one again
speech in the right direction on Monday
night but what the 3900 troops will be
able to accomplish how will we will be
able to get the Talib Ryan to the table
as Secretary Tillerson said yesterday
all of these are open questions the
other thing that I think in fairness to
President Trump we have to accept
we had nothing like the North Korean
threat back in the 60s or 70s even 80s
or 90s and when you had the framework
agreement in 1994 we were not facing a
situation or set of circumstances where
North Korea going nuclear was imminent
yes we bought 10 years of time that's
correct but they cheated and now
we are dealing with the aftermath of
that
so we face serious serious problems the
Middle East with Iran the Sunni Shiite
rivalry which is taking a different
shape but again we are facing challenges
again without a White House staff that
in a lot of ways is as experienced as
that which somebody like President Nixon
was able to to bring to bear we've seen
a great deal of turnover in the White
House in the last six or seven months
I think the papers in the last couple of
days I saw it in the New York Times if I
remember I think Wall Street Journal as
well I think they listed ten or twelve
people who'd lasted less than six months
again my point is not to say this one
should have stayed this one should have
gone whatever but to say if we have this
kind of turnover the loser is the United
States of America because we have a
government that appears and indeed may
well be inherently unstable so I am send
by what I see and I'm saddened by what
my party the Democrats are doing or not
doing to cooperate because we cannot
address the challenges we have with the
kind of political approach we have in
the book American the age of Trump that
I co-authored with Jessica Tarlov we had
10 basic propositions that we addressed
and what I'd like to do is articulate
the propositions give you a second to
think about each one and then go back
through some of the solutions we
proposed in our book and let me be very
clear we make the argument both
implicitly and explicitly that if there
were people of goodwill getting together
has happened in the 60s and 70s we could
solve a great deal and many of the
issues and challenges we face but in the
absence of that and the hyper
politicization
of our system where everything is a
campaign event and everything evolves at
an attack ad sadly our challenges have
gone unaddressed so first and I think
this is fair to say the American
education system is a failure at every
level and we'll talk about that in a
second but I would really tell you one
of the experiences that I've had
whenever I talk to immigrants and I say
how was your education system compared
to where you came here compared to where
you came from people who would extol the
virtue of America say that we're they're
Patriots they love this country we don't
know what we have always say their
educational system is is superior to be
sure we have some very very good
universities here but I would say we
have a challenge to educate people and
particularly a challenge in poor
communities and I I would just say one
thing about that we are one nation
whether you're a Republican or Democrat
you can't govern just to protect
minorities or to protect upper-middle
class whites you have to be inclusive
whatever your approach and so far again
I have yet to see a politician or a
political party take an inclusive
approach to education and indeed most
most issues we have another problem that
I think most of you have seen certainly
as the parent of a 26 year old son
trying to make his way in the world I
see it myself the economy to be sure is
strong and it's recovering but wages are
stagnant the middle class is hollowing
out and the American Dream is on life
support I think many of us certainly may
grew up believing whatever happened we
do better and I do better than my
parents
my parents were successful I am proud of
them proud of what they were able to
offer to me but I I there was no sense
that I would face the kind of challenges
I see young people facing today and
those challenges have to do with
affordability they have to do with
getting good jobs and they have to do
with just the simple challenges we face
in dealing with a very complicated world
where our educational system is not
necessarily preparing people for the
challenges we face or the for challenges
that they face the third proposition is
and I was was something I alluded to
before we are approaching a national
emergency of military readiness and
preparedness in a world of mounting
security threats now we wrote the book
oh I guess about finished in about six
months a year ago we didn't anticipate
precisely what's happened but again you
didn't have to be a prophet to figure
out the challenges that trump was going
to face from the Russians the Chinese
and as I've suggested rogue nations like
North Korea and Iran we also have a
criminal justice system which is our
fourth point that does a good job
punishing people who commit serious
crimes but it's also senseless a
sentencing many of our young men and
women guilty of less serious offenses to
long sentences and June futures now I
think we could debate the policy and
approach that attorney General Sessions
is taking and I certainly believe
President Obama may well have gone too
far with his pardons at the end of his
second term but I think it's also the
case that we have one of the highest
incarceration rates in the world and we
have very very limited resources to both
teach and train people in prison to come
out
and be productive citizens put another
way we do have an underclass in this
country and one of the ways we're seeing
it reflected is what's come to be called
the opioid crisis candidly Jessica and I
did not write about that in any great
detail but now as we watch the median
I'm pleased the president declared a
national emergency we have what I think
is 50 odd thousand people dying every
year and you run across people who are
you know taking prescription drugs quite
apart from heroin and cocaine and waking
up and finding themselves addicted to
some pain medication anti-anxiety
medication and it is literally for them
crippling we don't have a handle on how
to deal with it we don't we don't have
the resources and even if we have the
resources it's not clear to me we know
how to to best handle that
I think it's obvious to everybody and
again this was written before the fight
over repeal and replace we have a health
care crisis because while I'd be the
first one to criticize the Republicans
for having seven years to come up with
an alternative plan it's also the case
that Obamacare is a failure exchanges
are collapsing insurers are pulling out
and premiums are going up by
double-digit amounts or more the other
thing we have which we haven't heard
much about lately but still remains a
problem is an entitlement crisis we may
well have deferred that for a while
we're not going to have a Medicare
Medicaid and Social Security go bankrupt
to the next couple of years but I think
the actuarial reports indicate that
in within 10-15 years we could face a
very serious crisis there's one other
issue this is actually my sixth point
which I think informs everything as
something we were talking about at lunch
today which is that there is never been
a time in my memory and I think the
polling bears this out that the public
has had such little faith in our
institutions what why is that well we've
all seen how Washington or state
governments have failed us I I think
it's fair to say that the level of
skepticism is high but there are a
couple of things going on that
exacerbate the problem which is
increasingly people are deciding why
would you want to serve in government
we're not getting our best people to go
into into government to serve the other
thing is with the internet and a very
very aggressive media we live in a
gotcha society and in a gotcha society
whatever you've done however you've done
it can be magnified and turned into a
problem and to say to somebody give up
your career step out leave your job go
into the administration whatever
administration democrat or republican
run the risk of some degree of
condemnation or excoriation for what you
did or what you didn't do
why would you do that and I ask that as
a rhetorical question but I think for
many many people that is also a huge
huge issue another issue we isolated is
that there's a crisis of values and what
I mean by that is basically we were
brought up at least I think virtually
everyone in this room and hopefully
those watching the vast majority with a
sense of right and wrong a sense of
morality decency and integrity that's
largely gone we live now in a
transactional society where the issue is
not am i doing the right thing or not
but candidly am I gonna get over oh the
other guy and and it's a zero-sum
society and it reflects I think an
underlying decay in what has made our
country unique and I did something last
night that I would urge everyone here to
please consider doing which is to watch
john f kennedy's inaugural address from
i think it was January 20th 1961 and his
point was that our sense of freedom and
liberty came not from our government
though our government was certainly to
be involved in promoting them around the
world but from our religious faith and
our religious belief and that was a
common thread in our political life I
can remember as a child the pride I had
in saying the Pledge of Allegiance the
pride I had and watching space launches
and a sense that this was a unique
experiment and democracy that had never
been replicated and never will be
replicated that's what I grew up with
most people I knew growing up had that
view I think that's all gone now sure we
can brain blame President Obama or
President Trump or George W Bush you can
blame a lots of people but I think the
the societal challenges that we face are
huge and palpably obvious there's one
other issue that one of my teachers
colleagues friends and even employers
wrote about in 1965 which is the
structure of the American family is in
collapse US Senate of the late Senator
Daniel Patrick Moynihan a professor of
mine
wrote the Moynihan report about the
crisis of the black family now it's not
the crisis of the black family
it's the crisis of the family and I
think for many of you you can recognize
as you just look around that kids who
come from families which are
single-parent tend to have less good
outcomes than those who are from stable
families and the number of stable
families has declined from I think a
sizeable majority when I was growing up
to a very small minority of households
today and again this is not a racial
issue this is an issue that crosses
racial economic political lines and
again I think isn't responsible is
responsible in part for why we have the
kind of drug problem that we do that I
was alluding to before the other the
tenth point we make which I think was
our effort to sum this all up which is
to say the future of the American ideal
is very much in question it used to be
that the world accepted that we were
unique arguably superior and offering
benefits as a society and a people that
arguably you couldn't find anywhere else
now we've really had the retreat of
America I do blame certainly President
Obama for that the leading from behind
we're not unique we're not special all
of that but it to me it's a larger issue
than pointing a finger at a politician
it is a sense that perhaps our culture
or our popular culture is to be desired
but there's not much else about America
that needs to be venerated so those are
my 10 and Jessica and my 10 concerns let
me quickly summarize what we recommend
what we think is practical and then
answer the question
what Richard Nixon would do look I
mathematics and science needs a
specialized attention college is
unaffordable student loans are out of
control
we need every possible kind of
experiment we can have vouchers charter
schools need to be expanded we need to
expand community colleges and vocational
training we just have to recognize that
a four-year college experience is not
necessarily right for everyone we need
to train people for the jobs that exist
not the jobs we think they should have
and while I think many of us have had a
liberal education liberal arts education
and profited from it I certainly did
it's not right for everyone we have to
accept that as a society and try to
organize our society as well III think
we really need to understand that unless
we are able to do that we will not be
able to address the issues of social
mobility job growth job creation in a
way that is constructive because so many
people even if they believe in the
American Dream believe it's gotten much
more difficult much more complicated and
ultimately for many illusory and what
I'd like to do and I think we can do it
with some hard-headed leadership in the
educational and job training fields is
we can make a real real dent in to that
I believe we do need comprehensive tax
reform I think the president from what I
know is going in the right direction but
we need pro-growth tax reform not merely
redistribution I'm with the
administration there
we need efforts to help lower-income
workers train them give them
opportunities and we need pro-family
policies that encourage and strengthen
our families rather than allowing them
to
continue to disintegrate look I'd be one
of those people and please you can
question me in the question period about
this but I am somebody who Steve Bannon
would call a globalist I think that we
have a role in the world we have a clear
role in the world and when the president
said oh we can't do nation building I
get that it's unpopular believe me I'm a
pollster by training I know what's
popular or not but unless we strengthen
the institutions of democracy in
countries like Afghanistan we'll have a
result like we've had in Iraq where the
forces of evil to wit Iran continue to
undermine stable democratic government
and in Afghanistan we have the Haqqani
network we have the Taliban we have Isis
we have to strengthen government's to be
competitive III just think we need to
foster our global cooperation I'm
disappointed I with the withdrawal from
the TPP I'm concerned about
renegotiation of NAFTA even if there's
short term political and perhaps even
economic benefit there but I think that
we need to recognize that we have a
serious issue in cybersecurity we have
the capacity to fight wars on that level
as well as conventionally and I think we
need to be more aggressive and more
assertive than we were certainly during
campaign 2016 look I just think in terms
of criminal justice that
is the we can't attack America and
American institutions for mass
incarceration I think that to see it in
racial terms and see it as the new
segregation or apartheid misses the
point we got to train people we got to
give them opportunities if they are in
jail we have to give them an opportunity
to be pointed in the right direction in
terms of rehabilitation education and
ultimately job training but I don't see
it as a racial issue but I do see it as
a crisis if we can't take people who are
in prison and give them a clear path to
a successful life
those small programs that have attempted
have had great success the problem is
there really a from what I can tell a
drop in the bucket and I think we need
more and better police training more
community outreach if you look and again
I'm not saying this to credit though I
think he deserves a lot my client friend
Michael Bloomberg but crime under his
leadership and continuing under Bill
DeBlasio has gotten to record lows the
number of murders again record lows
clearly in Chicago something has gone
wrong and again I'm not sitting here
saying it's Rahm Emmanuel's fault but
the degree of gang membership and
alienation from the police is so
substantial that there's literally a
crisis of Society societal leadership
given the exploding and expanding murder
rate so that is again something we need
to do and again we have to address the
entitlement crisis I believe now and we
need to do it with small fixes now so we
don't have to do big fixes ray you know
some degree of modest means testing
raising excuse me raising the retirement
age
where benefits would be available by a
few months maybe a year or so small
fixes like that now can save the
programs from for the future I also
believe more choice more competition in
our programs as good as a practical
matter we got to do something about
healthcare I would have been only too
happy for repeal and replace to succeed
now we have to take what is and try to
fix it with more market competition more
efforts to I think make sure that
insurance companies do not pull out of
markets entirely I'm not an expert on
health care but I do know this as a
matter of politics if we do not address
the health care crisis this system could
well very quickly be in complete
collapse and I believe that the
government has to face the crisis that
we see in faith in our institutions
there has to be an effort for
responsiveness on all levels from local
government to the federal government
there has to be an openness there has to
be a responsiveness of the government to
citizens and if we can do that maybe
just maybe we can turn that around I
suggest that we also have to deal with
the crisis and values the crisis and the
family and we have to do though
explicitly I don't think there's too
many people talking about it but unless
we recognize that those are huge
challenges I don't think that we are
going to in a way that's fundamental I
don't think we're going to change the
underlying mix I do think in terms of
the vacuum and political leadership we
need to get rid of things like you know
partisan we dis redistricting I I think
the fact that so few elections are
competitive maybe 50 or 60 of the 435
House races will be competitive and the
way the fun you know and I'm not here to
say I'm poor citizens
against citizens united I have my
opinions but if we're in a situation
where politicians don't campaign they're
just fundraise and they deal with
special interests we are doomed to fail
and we have to we have to recognize that
and my final point is we have to
recognize that the American ideal is at
risk we have to recognize that our
position globally we is eroding numerous
commentators have spoken of that
numerous political leaders are basically
saying look you guys have quit you're
off the global stage in a leadership way
we have to deal with the new reality I
think that said I think that's wrong but
I think it's fundamentally reversible
and I also think as we sit here today
and I'll stop in a second but President
Nixon would have approached this all
very differently looking at his record
as I did in the Nexen effect and
thinking about America in the age of
Trump as I as I did President Nixon
would have tried to find a bipartisan
solution to each and every of these
problems he would have called the
congressional leadership Democratic and
Republican and he would have sought to
craft bipartisan solutions the other
thing the president would have done
would he would have presentation would
do today is he would lower his voice and
if you remember the first term the
attack dog nattering nabobs of
negativism was vice president Spiro
Agnew right now the roles are reversed
Donald Trump is the one who's out there
talking and Mike Pence is the quiet
behind-the-scenes political operator I'm
not suggesting that Mike Pence should go
out there and become something he's not
but rather I'm suggesting this country
would profit and benefit by the
president lowering his voice not
attacking his own party not just
attacking the Democrats - but saying how
do we get this done how do we work
together as I said I was very moved on
Monday night by this speech it certainly
is going in the right direction but I
think these rallies however good they
make the president and his supporters
feel really further divide our country
and put us in a position where we are
less equipped to deal with the
challenges facing our country look I'm
an optimist before I am a a partisan or
an ideologue I'm an American I believe
deeply in this country I believe deeply
in our values and I believe deeply in
what we have done as Democrats and
Republicans to make this still the
greatest country that has ever been put
together and assembled I believe that
the Nixon Library as an institution
stands for those values it certainly has
a larger purpose given invitations to a
wide range of speakers on a wide range
of subjects with a variety of different
perspectives I want to make it very very
clear that this is the third time I've
been here it is a great great pleasure
to come from New York not only to be in
sunny California but but to be with here
with such sunny and optimistic people
who have been so patient listening to me
so let me stop and open it up to
questions thank you thank you Doug yes
sir
is there anyone with a mic right right
here okay sure I want you on Fox you're
very good thank you sir you're one of
the few that I actually believe is
trying to be honest but you're gonna
have to help me out here I'll try on the
one side being a white retired
businessman fairly successful I looked
on the one side in the african-american
library not the Museum in Washington has
no mention of Clarence Thomas anywhere
right and on the other side the service
Sounion is going to have a black lives
matter exhibit and they're going to take
colin kaepernick stuff you know maybe
they can get his Fidel Castro Jersey or
something so I'm trying to see and
rationalize that with the Democrats that
are demonizing they're not just
resisting they're subversive
by calling the average white guy
successful or not you know all the
things they spew so my question is is
when you look at Howard Dean and what
they're saying what good does that do
the country not much sir and first of
all I congratulate you for your success
I would agree with the basic premise
that unless we accept that we are an
inclusive country
that there's a diversity of opinion a
diversity of background in all
communities african-american Asian
Hispanic and white unless we do that
through all our institutions we all lose
so I would say what you described to me
saddens me I share some of the same
sentiments with you I probably wouldn't
put it in his blunt terms as you have
but I would say this I grew up in the
civil rights mode my mother taught me
that we were to be as Martin Luther King
said you know values free colorblind and
to deal with the content of people's
character that's the way I choose to see
things and I would hope the polarization
on the left and the right in the
african-american community in all
communities can be dissipated you're
right to criticize the Democrats there's
much I would dare say say the
Republicans can be criticized for it too
but I return to where I started we're
Americans first and unless we pull
together inclusively we all fail yes
ma'am you a question right here oh sure
please okay first of all I've always
appreciated your level-headed comments
and on a scale of one to ten I gave you
a six in my appreciation and today
you're at ten and same with Jessica I've
always for a Democrat I always liked her
and now she's a ten if she had anything
to do with a book she's a ten did you
say yeah yeah and I'm a six no no you
were a six now you're a 10 oh well thank
you and I think you're a closeted
Republican
coming out in in light of what we've
seen in the media recently regarding the
violence etc with these this whole
resist and anta is there anything that's
going to happen in your mind to expose
what's really going on there and somehow
get some control of the violence
unmasking these people and arresting
them for what's going on who would you
like to arrest on the right or the left
or both yeah I must tell you I really
believe we have to do everything within
the law to discourage the kind of
violent protests we've had now I don't
for a second I want to be very clear and
I said this before but I deserves
reiteration I do not see neo-nazis and
white supremacist as the equivalent of
those on the left however much those on
the Left I find are doing destructive
acts I think white separatism Nazism I
say this is an American Jew who had
relatives unfortunately who perished in
the Holocaust I think those are so far
outside the American tradition that I
cannot equate them but that being said
we don't need violence on either either
side I absolutely agree with that I
think the protests are destructive and I
also think that what the
a counter protesters are have done in
some instances have been harmful to the
broader cause that they espouse and
certainly that I believe in I think
Boston at least was handled a lot better
than Charlottesville but I'd rather move
to a situation where we don't have
weekend demonstrations week after week
after week we focus on dealing in as
sober minded away as I can talk about it
on the problems we have you and I may
differ about who's doing what but where
we don't differ I am convinced is
wanting the best for a unified United
States of America we have a question
right here yes sir real quickly does Fox
have any plans to resurrect the
political insiders well I very much
enjoyed doing the show with Pat Caddell
and John leboutillier I don't know of
any plans now but I really am very very
grateful to the entire leadership of Fox
for giving us a chance to to do the
program will question the front roll
most of the things that you have talked
about today and I really appreciated
them as a mother and grandmother and
great-grandmother
and someone who worked in the schools
for at least 12 years it's a tremendous
fight for you to have values in your
home and those values are not accepted
nor approved of in the schools and I
will say that with everything in me
because I've seen it so often I saw it
early on when I worked in the schools it
was very subtle but it was not in
keeping with this is a good nation and
that we are good people all I have to do
is look at each grandchild of mine who
was raised with the same values
who came out of college and different
colleges and universities with a totally
changed attitude toward who America is
well first of all I've a couple of
reactions first of all let me say how
proud I am to meet you in this forum
what you've done makes you and my terms
a true American Hero both in terms of
family and in terms of education this is
what makes America great so first let me
say thank you to you for just having led
your life the way you have that's number
one number two I couldn't agree more one
of the reasons why I think charter
schools are so important
most of them impart and insist on
uniforms values attendance all the stuff
we grew up with taking for granted they
insist upon and the outcomes are
extraordinary that they achieve so I can
only say that the other or the third
issue that I heard you address is one
that I would agree with I'm a great
believer in freedom of speech but
freedom of speech does not go one way it
is not freedom of speech to be on the
left it is freedom of speech to mouth
whatever views you hold when I went to
college there was some assault on it but
now many years later I know people who
were proud conservatives intellectuals
who say the following
I can't tell people what I think they'll
run me out and these are not people who
are to be I'm just blunt about it
they're not chickens they're not afraid
of their own shadows
they're just realistic they don't want
to put their lives and their livelihoods
at risk in any way that would subject
them to you know demonstrations or
protests and the like and I think that's
very very sad and I couldn't agree with
you more and I'll just conclude by
saying again thank you and I'm proud to
meet you
we have a question the front row sure hi
um thank you I'm a big fan I see seen
you on Fox News a line I'm sorry
my question is how worried should
Americans be about the left sort of
trying to adopt a socialist platform and
bring back socialism to America well III
think it's a very good question look I
am a proud capitalist as I said I'm for
free markets you know free enterprise
all of that it's how I've led my own
life and how I think this country was
formed I also believe in a robust and
healthy social safety net we might agree
or perhaps disagree on how extensive
expansive and extensive and yes even
expensive such a social safety net would
be but that's in the context of a
capitalist system I do worry and I think
you're right that these fundamental
premises that undergird our society have
been attacked by those on the left and
on the Democratic Left who appear to
advocate for socialism senator Sanders
being one of them some of his critique
makes some sense but what he recommends
is basically state-run societies which I
think are abhorrent and I think they are
inherently dangerous to logical and
consistent economic growth and to basic
freedom so I think the answer is we got
to be worried I never thought the
Democratic Party would become
effectively a socialist party but it's
sure moving in that direction not
everybody is that way but the energy and
the strength and the Democratic Party
are those who put redistribution ahead
of capitalism we have a question right
here
hi there each of the issues you
identified in the 10 points require our
governor governor governing body to come
together and work on a common goal how
does that happen
boy if you had an answer I'll be the
first one to campaign for you and I
couldn't agree more I I sort of think
and the reason why I was so thrilled
that the Nixon Library invited me that
unless people like you and I'd like to
say myself make the argument and speak
out we're never gonna succeed I can't
say I have a magic formula or a clear
way to achieve it but I can say this we
have to speak out we have to be unafraid
and we have to bring the approach and
values that you clearly have depression
right here hi so in the 16 election or
in the 16 campaign on a democratic side
you could see that the bench was very
monochromatic very old very rich so who
do you see as the up-and-comers when
Nancy Pelosi finally decides to get out
of the way the Democratic Party who do
you see is the up-and-comers for the
Democrats to challenge Trump in the next
election boy I wish I knew it's a great
question and I get it relatively often
and while I could give you names I can't
give you a Barack Obama the way and you
could see in 2007 and certainly 2008
that he was emerging III I wish I had a
name and I think one of the problems to
your point again sir is that the
Democratic Party is bereft of talent
that can provide national leadership and
I'd be the first one to tout a national
leader and hope such a person emerges
but so far we have a lot of maybes
wannabes and potentially again Bernie
Sanders who I believe the fields
notwithstanding his age and worldview
that it is his
right and responsibility to run and try
to beat Donald Trump no question the
front row you mentioned at the beginning
the dismal state of education in the
United States and how we are ranked very
low in the world in terms of
international testing one of the top
countries in the world is Finland it
ranks in the top three every single year
I read the book by the head of the
Finnish educational system and he has
adopted Finland has adopted the 1940s
and 50s the United States recommended
program of progressive education John
Dewey University of Chicago progressive
education movement and as an educator I
have used his the materials which are
quite clear in terms of take each child
from where he as to as far as he can go
and to use the scientific method in all
of our teaching why has the United
States dropped a program which was
inherently successful to come up with a
rote fill-in-the-blanks true or false
tech boy I wish I knew the answer to
your question which is why did we cease
defeat from the jaws of success and I
don't have a quick or good answer to
that I wish I did but it's you know I'll
just speak personally which I can do I'm
an employer the number of people I hire
who write and read and write seamlessly
even from very good schools pretty
limited I give you another personal
example I tried to offer internships to
a diverse audience I'm proud to do that
I think that's what we all should do I
have had to teach some people just basic
rules like you show up on time you do
your work on time you sit still you
don't leave your desk or your post until
you know it's break time or lunch time
you don't decide on Thursday that you
really need along with
long weekend and disappear and I say all
this there was one year we had interns
where I could tell it was the weekend
because on Thursday afternoon they all
brought their suitcases to the job and
you know they were gone and look I don't
want to be unfair
these are interns they're not full-time
employees but as we've been saying today
the values and the strictures of our
society that which has made us great
have largely been compromised I'm not
against evolving we have to there are
new kinds of employment technical
technological jobs that require
different kind of training but for
goodness sake why are we moving in a way
that is clearly doomed for failure that
I do not know and your question to me is
largely unanswerable sadly we have time
for one more question
right here thank you very much it's been
very informative the thing I wanted to
ask was your input on immigration sure
good question
and you know we didn't really address
that in a central way we should have and
I look I believe that there is a fairly
straightforward though very contentious
solution I think we have to protect our
borders absolutely that's first and
foremost
whatever your ideology but I think for
the 11 million people who were here here
as illegals particularly those that are
paying their taxes contributing to
society to deny them a chance to be
citizens or a chance to get green cards
is to me wrongheaded and for them to
live in fear as many do I think is a
mistake for our society now let me be
very clear I'm not I'm not advocating
amnesty if we have those who are not
productive especially those who have
committed crimes get them out get them
to I you know I should boosh be in every
city
forget this sanctuary city stuff we
don't need sanctuary cities we need the
rule of law in this country but but just
to underscore I am NOT for just you know
persecuting those who have been here I
want to provide the opportunity that is
appropriate to those who have already
proven they can contribute to our
society the interesting thing about your
question ma'am is if you poll the
American people and ask them about some
version of what I said
you'll get fifty five sixty percent who
will agree in some way or another
indicating that you could get a
bipartisan solution the sad thing is
between the Democrats who take one
extreme position the Republicans another
extreme position this is another issue
that we can and should and must resolve
that sadly appears that it will not be
resolved anytime soon so thank you very
much thank you Doug Doug will be
available to sign your book America in
the age of Trump thank you again for
being here and we'll see you next time